vender hachís de 44 mil habitantes sólo
quedan 10 mil en plena ofensiva rusa
sobre la región de jarquín viajamos a
este pueblo en la última gran localidad
ante las aldeas ocupadas por el ejército
ruso el alcalde de la comarca explica
que los bombardeos son constantes y
resistir está haciendo el juicio todo
según auguró maps ahora el enemigo está
caóticamente bombardeando nuestra ciudad
destruyendo casas y comercios ahora este
proyecto a una llamada de teléfono
interrumpe la entrevista el alcalde
tiene que atender al ejército en muchos
pueblos ocupados falta comida no hay
electricidad ni gas
el enemigo está agrupando fuerzas
adicionales militares y de armamento en
las zonas fronterizas de los territorios
ocupados la situación es muy difícil
este era el centro de cultura de la
ciudad de deraa y ha quedado
completamente destrozado aquí se
repartía ayuda humanitaria los
habitantes temen que las tropas rusas
avancen algunos como nikola han
escuchado los relatos
mi hermano es latino
la bombardearon allí y ahora está
avanzando hasta aquí
con las tropas rusas a pocos kilómetros
los destrozos se acumulan en este pueblo
de la primera línea incluso las iglesias
ortodoxas rusas han sido bombardeadas
alexander un estudiante universitario
que trabaja con el alcalde propone ir al
hospital pero a último minuto la cita se
cancela
lamentablemente no podemos ir ahora la
situación es muy tensa una niña de ocho
años murió durante una cirugía le habían
traído después de un bombardeo
después de semanas en las que la guerra
parecía haber dado una tregua las zonas
al norte de jarquín vuelven a sufrir las
consecuencias de la nueva ofensiva rusa